in november 2021 former tsm player
doublelift accused the organization's
owner reginald of harassing and abusing
its members after a war of words between
the two we didn't hear much until last
week when news broke that riot games and
tsm were launching their own separate
investigations into the allegations
we're going to be discussing the
allegations against reginald and the
implications of these investigations for
both him and one of the world's biggest
esports organizations
now before i dive into this video i just
wanted to let you know that we published
our latest episode of our newest show
every second counts presented by cisco
in this episode we go deep on the
underdog story of edg besting damon
gaming in the most recent league of
legends worlds finals click the link in
the description below to check out the
video all right before we dive too
deeply into the investigations it's
important to quickly cover the reason
they're happening now doublelifts
accusations doublelift has had a long
and well-documented history with reggie
and large parts of it have not exactly
been harmonious between 2015 and 2021
doublelift joined and left tsm on
multiple occasions first as a player for
their league of legends team and then
later as a streamer for them double his
final season as a tsm player finished
with a disastrous 0-6 appearance at
worlds after which he left the team and
retired he cited a number of personal
reasons for this including winning
worlds being unrealistic and that simply
making it out of groups was an
unfulfilling goal for him some people
were surprised by his departure
especially because csm were bringing in
veteran chinese support soda at that
time but in november 2021 while still
streaming under the tsm banner
doublelift slammed reggie and tsm on
stream and shed some light on what
really went down honestly i [ __ ] hate
dsm
because
mostly because of andy
i actually remember this now yeah sword
art called me afterwards and said i'm
coming to tsm are you sure like he still
want to play with me and then
uh
i called andy and told him yeah sword
still wants to play with me um
and i would love to you know continue to
play for the org and andy literally said
no because he's got too much of an ego
reginald hit back with a reddit post in
which he disputed doublelift's version
of events and said that he assumed
doublelift was quote upset because we
weren't interested in working with him
now this was the point where it went
from a public spat about a player
leaving a team to something far more
serious the next day doublelift levelled
some pretty disturbing allegations
against his former boss
people don't like working with them it's
funny that he has his holier than that
attitude about it because
he's like a bully who gets away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what i'm sick of
that when i was talking to my friends
last night on discord that's what i
realized
is that like
i'm sick of
somebody who's basically just a bully
getting away with it because it's in
everyone's best interests and not
getting in his way there have been
rumors about reggie's behavior over the
years but nothing quite as stark as this
especially because it was coming from
perhaps the single most famous lcs
player of all time and one who had seen
many iterations of tsm come and go over
the years there were those who backed up
what doublelift was saying but also
former players who either came to
reddy's defense or at the very least
tried to defuse the situation
surrounding him much to doublelift shock
even cloud9's owner jack etienne played
down reggie's management style as brash
and blunt during the time that he worked
with him so there was a massive uproar
about this and then everything seemed to
die down until last week that's when
wyatt shared an article in which riot
games told them via email that quote we
are aware of the allegations made about
the ceo slash owner of tsm as the league
operator we have engaged the law firm of
omelvany and myers llp to conduct an
independent investigation into claims of
misconduct made against the leader of
this team in accordance with standard
league process wyatt also spoke to a
number of tsm employees one of whom
alleges they were subject to mental
abuse by reggie other individuals told
them of being dominated by a culture of
fear at tsm of being called stupid or
worthless by reggie or being called by
him after work hours to be screamed at
one of wyatt's sources alleged that
reggie would make an employee cry at
least every other week this echoed what
doublelift said when we first covered
this story back in november in fact
doublelift said that reggie's verbal
abuse of players was enough to trigger
mental breakdowns in some of them he
made
so many players cry i don't want to name
them actually because
i feel like it's it's not my story to
tell
so i would just say that he made a lot
of players cry you would be very [ __ ]
surprised
at how many of maybe your your favorite
familiar faces in lcs
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they were just getting verbally
assaulted now when doublelift raised
these accusations of mental abuse
against reggie we didn't hear a reply
from him but this time we did when he
responded to wired over email he said he
has quote exceedingly high expectations
for myself and i share those same high
expectations with everyone i work with i
have zero tolerance for under
performance i am intense passionate
driven and relentless in the pursuit of
winning it's my nature i set an
extremely high bar and when i feel that
someone is not delivering i directly and
bluntly share that feedback i know i
need to work on my delivery and i am
working to improve the way i communicate
with my team and those around me i
support and i'm fully cooperating with
the independent investigations that are
already underway and will gladly embrace
any recommendations from the
investigators for some people like
cadrell though these admissions were too
little too late had to work on his
delivery yeah i don't know i don't know
i don't like that i know i need to work
on my delivery if 10 years ago he was
flaming dyrus and now he's doing the
same thing still and he's saying that 10
years later he needs to work on his
delivery yeah i don't buy that i don't
buy that [ __ ] personally a tsm
spokesperson also told wire that they've
launched an internal investigation
involving an independent
subcommittee with the assistance of
outside legal counsel and an independent
investigator they added that reggie has
withdrawn himself from anything
regarding the scope nature and
conclusions of the investigation so we
have two investigations at play here the
tsm one has already been mocked on
social media with some people in the
community questioning just how
accountable the org can really hold its
owner now the presumption here is that
any real repercussions will come from
riots investigation and the legal team
they've hired to help them with this but
is that fair to assume riot are saying
their investigation began when
doublelift made his public remarks back
in november but there have been rumors
about this sort of stuff going on at tsm
for years and it wasn't just behind
closed doors in our last video we shot
examples of videos that have been public
for a long time one involved former tsm
top lane odyrus being badgered by reggie
until he finally exploded
i'm playing a game dude
all right i'm sorry for being rooted
then
i'll be home brad you're
[Applause]
another example was former tsm support x
special being brought to tears after a
heated post game exchange with reggie
like you're the best league at your
sport that's why you went to awesome
it's really obvious
it's really obvious but
people need to do what they're really
good at and my mechanics aren't that
good i'm really good at shot calling and
that's why i specialize in and when when
someone
when someone tells me like
their judgment is better than my game i
get really frustrated i can't i can't
play well because that's why i'm
spending most of my time perhaps the
most famous case with over one million
views is another dispute between reggie
annex special as reggie argues that wild
turtle who was sitting next to him was
the main reason for a recent loss the
biggest factor was certainly okay and
you're arguing with me arguing through
my back no
for no reason you're arguing with me an
argument is annoying and you've always
been doing this it's really getting
annoying okay
and lately you've been doing it it's so
annoying now some of these clips come
from the team's early days when reggie
was not just the owner of the
organization but also one of the players
on his lcs team reggie was part owner
part player part friend to these tsm
players all at the same time this
context has often been used by people to
explain away what we're seeing in these
clips the wild west of esports when
things were just less professional but
does that make it okay should riot have
investigated this kind of stuff years
ago and these clips are only known to us
because they appeared on a stream or an
old documentary series doublelift
speaking out and the tsm employees that
wyatt have spoken to suggest that
allegedly this thing may be deeper wider
and more recent than those clips would
suggest and perhaps that is what has
given cause for riot to look into this
whole thing the question is what will
come of their investigation if the
allegations are true will they bring
down the hammer on reggie or will they
pull their punches when it comes to the
head of one of the biggest esports orgs
in the lcs of course riot are more
removed than tsmr from their own
investigation but they're not isolated
from it either they have a vested
interest in the success and reputation
of the lcs and that will always bring
any judgment from their investigation
into question it offers the age-old
question who pleases the police them
calling upon the help of an outside
legal team shows that they recognize
this fact but will it be enough to add
legitimacy to their findings in the eyes
of the community in 2019 riot gave echo
fox an ultimatum after their owner rick
fox accused a shareholder in his company
of racism either he steps down from the
org or echo fox would be kicked from the
lcs echo fox left the lcs of their own
accord it's the only real precedent we
have of what riot can and might do if
their investigation finds these
allegations to be true they wouldn't
have any direct power over tsm but they
can draw their own line in the sand and
force their hand now we don't know
exactly when riot will be publishing the
results of their ongoing investigation
but this all comes at a time when they
themselves are paying out 100 million
dollars to current and former female
employees as part of a huge gender
discrimination lawsuit settlement by
their own rule book they are within
their right to carry out this
investigation and pass judgment but will
the community see them as having moral
legitimacy when their own record of
employee treatment is in tatters to put
it lightly as for the findings of tsm's
internal investigation they're expected
to be released later this month when
they are we'll have a lot more to talk
about because this story is far from
over
you